now when you say it's about what makes
you special and having that special
something what do you think is yours I'm
such a dabbler that you are involved in
so many different dabbler is the key I
have called myself a master of be
talents a fast-food Renaissance man I've
had no particular skill and I'm not
being falsely modest about that i mean
if i could have been Chris Rock or
Robert De Niro or Robin Thicke I would
have been but instead the beauty of my
career and experience has been the
variety of it I've been able to do a
bunch of things okay something's better
than others I've always considered my
have a craft I would say it's writing
I've won many more awards as a writer
than I have as an actor and its really
what I started doing what I continue to
do and that gives me great pleasure
isn't that interesting though because
most people consider you America's dad
they don't think of you as a writer and
Canadians Canada's dad of course too but
they don't immediately consider you or
think of you as a writer musician no no
trooper talk show well you know we're
all very fortunate if anything happens
in our career that is so outstanding or
memorable or resonates as growing pains
did through no fault of my own that was
an ensemble cast and we had an
incredibly hot teen idol and kirk
cameron and it was a good show that ran
for seven years so if any of us is ever
lucky enough to have one of those in a
lifetime in career you really have to
embrace that enjoy it milk it milk it
always work and I'm perfectly happy to
be identified mostly by that no well
it's a beautiful show that I think a lot
of people identify with and it I mean
we're kind of raised by it yeah that's
the family you wanted to have that you
wanted to be a part of I know I did and
and in a way it was an end of an era
because around that time yet who's the
boss family ties growing pains caused be
full house and
the Nielsen researchers discovered that
most households had two television sets
so they no longer had the program one
show for the family and what they used
to call the family hour now they get
have a grown-up show in a kids show and
that's what has evolved and that's why
they don't make shows like that anymore
and that's why we're in reruns and
that's good Wow but you're just blowing
my mind I never thought about it that
way that makes sense yeah I understand
you had a reunion with the Seaver clan
just reason we did have a reunion on
unusually thick that's our new show on
slice and kind of a hybrid reality and
sitcom we'd start with the real family
in real situations but we had a little
fun to it and try to get out with a
laugh and on was so the real life
circumstance was that we were having a
growing pains reading in barbecue and in
real life Kirk Cameron the last minute
couldn't show so we sent a little skype
video but then we had to turn that into
a story where I was pretending to get
the group together to pitch them all a
feature film receiver family and then we
didn't have Mike Seaver so we create a
scene where I go and visit with John
Stamos and I said how would you like to
become the new Mike Seaver in the film
and John says yeah like that as long as
you update it a little bit I think
deceivers should be vampires action gay
so i would say i'm not sure i have the
same vision as you job he was a really
good sport about it and we ended up but
that's an example of how would take in
real situations and make a story